- I want to thank Dr. Morrison
for his invitation to talk with you today,
and I was very happy to
share the classes on Tuesday,
which give me a real sense
of what this class is about
and what it's like,
and in particular, his comments,
very, very learned
comments, I want to say.
I was very impressed with
his grasp of Wittgenstein,
and about whom I think I know something,
and also, I was very, very enlightened
by what he had to say about William James.
I had just, I've just
come from New Hampshire,
where I spent Thanksgiving,
and that gave me a sense of the
where William James spent his last days,
last years, I think, yeah,
beautiful, beautiful
country you have here.
Oh my. America's so wonderful.
Anyway, speaking of Wittgenstein,
who was this man,
Maurice O'Connor Drury's teacher,
Wittgenstein wasn't terribly
impressed by these classes.
He says, "My lectures are going well.
"They will never go better,
"but what effect do they leave behind?
"Am I helping anybody?
"What day," his students
learned, "is not worth learning?
"And the personal impression I make
"does not serve them with anything."
That's true for all of them
with perhaps one or two exceptions,
so I'm looking around the class now
to see who the exceptions
are going to be. (chuckles)
However, I think it's evident
that at least in Wittgenstein's case,
in Cambridge University in England,
far more than one or two students
were deeply affected by his classes,
and very prominent among these
was Maurice O'Connor Drury.
That's a picture of him here.
I didn't bring all the equipment,
you know, the bells and whistles with you
because at any lecture I've been
in Ireland, anyway, in
the last couple of years,
the pictures broke down.
The computers just don't work,
and in my age group,
I'm just not enough of a
tech head to control that,
so this Maurice O'Connor
Drury is a central figure
that I want to discuss with you today,
and why Drury, here in this class?
It's clear that Drury
is relevant to medicine
and the humanities, HUMS 029.
Like most figures discussed in this class,
Drury was a physician.
He was a doctor,
but he wrote a highly regarded book
about medical practice from
a humanistic perspective.
He was an undergraduate
student of philosophy
at Cambridge University.
They didn't call it
philosophy at Cambridge.
They call it the moral sciences,
and he was tutored by Wittgenstein.
Drury had originally intended
to take orders in the Anglican Church.
In America here, that's
the Episcopalian community.
Rejecting that plan,
he aspired to a career
teaching philosophy,
but was guided by Wittgenstein
towards medicine instead,
and Wittgenstein continued
with a mentoring role
towards Drury's medical education
in Dublin in the late 1930s
through his early years
as a doctor in the royal,
the British Royal Army Medical
Corps during World War II,
and he recommended that after the war,
Drury should specialize in
psychiatry, which Drury did,
so this man had a huge
influence on his life,
on Drury's life.
Despite a very busy professional life,
Drury persisted in being
deeply involved in philosophy,
bringing to bear
what he had learned from
Wittgenstein in particular
to issues that arose in the
practice of his psychiatry,
and we're going to talk about that.
My own involvement in this story
is that I've assembled his writings,
previously published and
unpublished, in this book,
"The Selected Writings of
Maurice O'Connor Drury,"
and I think I mentioned to you last day,
it's published by the same
publisher as "Harry Potter,"
so that's my big claim to fame. (chuckles)
The collection justifies considering him
alongside the physician writers
that are featured in your course,
Bulgakov, Henry Marsh, Atul Gawande,
and Lisa Sanders of the
Yale Medical School.
All have or are deploying perspectives
informed by the humanities
to enrich medical practice,
and actually, the last day
Dr. Morrison asked me to explain
why the humanities?
And I think the humanities' role
is to foster
or take care of your soul,
and what do I mean by your soul?
The Latin for soul is anima,
so it's what animates you,
what makes you alive
when you cry, when you smile,
when you're with friends,
when you're in love.
It's your soul,
so we have soul music.
It's a wonderful word,
and the humanities foster that.
That's what they're there.
You read a novel. You read a poem.
You listen to music.
You take part in a play.
You are at play. You dance.
That's what the humanity, it's your human,
what you can do as a human being
and to foster and strengthen that,
so Drury understood
that humanistic insight,
valuable for medical practice,
was not confined to his
subject, philosophy,
and in doctors,
and indeed, all of
those who have a concern
for how medicine is practiced
in civil society, generally,
could gain from reading,
and I quote from him,
"The great novelists, like Tolstoy,
"the dramatists,
biographers, and historians."
The person who brought
us here this morning
is about to, is a theater director
in Rhode Island, Providence,
and she's just starting next week
on a play called "The Faith Healers,"
and I would absolutely love
to be a kind of gofer with her,
you know, seeing how a play,
how you put a play together.
It's extraordinary.
Now, it seems to me
that this is the thesis
that underlies this course,
that medicine is the most...
Think about this. This is a quotation.
"The most humanistic of the sciences
"and the most scientific
"of the humanities."
It straddles...
Medicine, properly practiced,
is the most humanistic of the sciences
and the most scientific of the humanities.
As I've already said,
the predominant philosophical
influence on Drury
was Wittgenstein,
and Wittgenstein is regarded,
along with Martin Heidegger,
as the most innovative
philosophers of the 20th century,
and as I become clear to you,
Wittgenstein had a profound
interest in medicine,
and the focus of his interest in medicine
was Drury and his career,
but so, also, did Martin Heidegger,
the German philosopher.
Philosophy is kind of divided into two
styles of philosophy,
the anglophone philosophy,
which is what you would
probably mainly get here
in any English-speaking country,
like England, Ireland,
America, Canada, Australia,
you know, the former British Empire,
but Heidegger also had a
huge interest in medicine.
He was based in Germany,
and he gave rise
to what's called
phenomenological philosophy,
and for 10 years now,
he really did spoil his copybook
during the Second World War
because he kind of
collaborated with the Nazis
in the university system, and he said...
But he did have this seminar
in Switzerland after the
war for about 10 years
called the Zollikon Seminars,
and it was mainly for doctors
and mainly psychiatrists and philosophers,
and one of his quotations just,
I'm not going to spend
a lot of time with him,
but he said, "Blood
pressure can be measured,
"but not life pressures."
You can measure your blood pressure.
I can do it on my watch.
It's probably zooming right now,
but not your life pressures,
what's really bothering you.
Heart functioning can be measured,
but not the loss of heart or heartbreak,
and he focused on the
patient's experience of disease
in the form of pain or discomfort,
emotional distress and depression,
but that, in itself, is
not anything measurable,
and, of course, science has
to do with what's measurable.
"One cannot measure tears.
"Measures, at best, a fluid,
"but the drops of the
fluid are not the tears."
I think it's a beautiful
way of putting it.
I'm going to move away from Heidegger,
but we could have another talk
about the influence of
Heidegger on medicine.
It's widely accepted
that a journal kept by Drury as a student,
later published as "Conversations
With Wittgenstein,"
has contributed
the most compelling picture
of Wittgenstein available.
He was a magnetic personality.
He attracted interest and
has attracted interest
far outside the confines
of professional philosophy.
I don't know if you're
familiar with the film
"Dancing at Lughnasa,"
which involves Meryl Streep
as playing the main thing.
The author of that play
originally, Brian Friel,
contacted me once to say,
"I would like to write a play
"about Wittgenstein in Ireland,"
and, of course, I was very excited.
My 15 moments of fame had arrived,
and then he invited me
to the famous theater,
the Abbey Theater in Dublin,
and everybody was there, from
the president of the country,
for his new play called
"Give Me Your Answer, Do!"
I don't know if you
know the little song say
Daisy, Daisy, give me your answer, do.
Anyway, that was the name play,
and I was waiting with bated breath
to have him talk about, you know,
have the characters
talk about Wittgenstein,
but the play turned out
to be about a playwright
who could not write a
play about Wittgenstein,
(laughs) so there you are,
but Wittgenstein's personality
has attracted a enormous
amount of interest
outside of philosophy,
and the standard
biography of Wittgenstein,
by a man called Ray Monk,
called "Ludwig Wittgenstein:
The Duty of Genius,"
has written that it was Drury's journal,
the "Conversations With Wittgenstein,"
that first stimulated him
to imagine a biography of Wittgenstein.
What struck Monk
was how Drury's accounts
contrasted so vividly
with the pale shadow of the real man
that prevailed in Oxford
in the late 1980s.
By that time, Wittgenstein
was dead 10, 15 years,
and Monk was a student of
philosophy at the university,
and actually, he introduced this book
and described how, as a student,
he had gone off to London for the weekend.
He bought the journals,
a copy of Wittgenstein's journals.
He said, "I read it all the way up to the,
"on the bus back up to Oxford,
"and at that moment,
"I decided to write a
biography of Wittgenstein,"
and this authenticity is found
not only in Drury's journal,
but also in essays
which concentrated on the
philosophical problems
that arise in psychiatry and psychology,
which have been collected in Drury's book.
They were originally
talks to groups of doctors
in Dublin and Swansea
in England, in Wales,
and he then produced
"The Danger of Words,"
and Monk again wrote that,
"In its tone and its concerns,
"it was perhaps the most
truly Wittgensteinian work
"published by any of
Wittgenstein's students."
With all that in mind,
I propose to tell you a
little more about Drury
and his relationship with Wittgenstein,
a relationship that lasted from 1931,
when he first met him as a student,
until Wittgenstein's death
in 1951, over 20 years,
and now, however, as a
preliminary to that account,
I think it would be helpful
to situate the
Wittgenstein/Drury interaction
as a relatively modern instance
of an interaction between
Western philosophy and medicine,
and I say Western philosophy because,
and Western medicine,
because there are also
wonderful medicines,
Chinese medicines and Indian medicines
and medicines that are
in Indigenous communities
all over the world.
I mean, we have just
one version of medicine,
but it's the one that,
in this country and my
own country, predominates,
but this goes back a very long way,
the interaction between medicine and,
philosophy and medicine,
back to classical Greece,
and the famous Christian writer Tertullian
said it was like a
sisterhood between the two
because one was a quest
for truth, philosophy,
and the other was a quest for health,
but sometimes truth can be understood
as critical to health,
mental health in particular,
so this is why I'm going to bring you
a passage illustrating all of this
from one of Plato's dialogues, the Laws,
and it's in front of you here now.
He says, "A state's invalides
"include not only free
men, but slaves too."
As you know, there was an,
slaves were an integral part of that,
of ancient Greece,
and, "The state's invalides,
"who are not free, but slaves,
"are always being treated by other slaves,
"who either rush about on flying visits
"or wait to be consulted
in their surgeries."
Now, apparently, some people speculate
that this may have been written
at the time of a plague in Athens.
"This kind of doctor," the slave doctor,
"never gives any account
"of the particular illness
of the individual slave
"or is prepared to listen to one.
"He simply prescribes what he thinks best
"in the light of experience
"as if he had precise knowledge
"and with the self-confidence
of a dictator."
I'm telling you what to do.
"Then he dashes off on his way
to the next slave's patient,
"and so takes off his master's shoulders
"some of the work of attending the sick."
I don't know if you think this,
but this is so contemporary
it's unbelievable.
"The visits of the free
doctor, by contrast,
"are mostly concerned
"with treating the illnesses of free men.
"His method is to construct
an empirical case history
"by consulting the
invalide and his friends.
"In this way, he himself
learns something from the sick,
"and at the same time, he
gives the individual patient
"all the instructions he can.
"He gives no prescription
"until he has somehow gained
the invalide's consent.
"Then, coaxing him into
continued cooperation,
"he tries to complete his
restoration to health."
Now, which of the two methods is best used
by the physician or
director of bodily regimen,
of regiment, regimen, I think,
is what it should say there.
The trainer, the physical trainer,
was very important in ancient Greece,
as important as the doctor,
so the, you know, the man who,
for example, like a physiotherapist,
but somebody who kind of,
if you go to a gym and work, you know,
helps you to work yourself out, work out.
He said, "That which
affects the same result
"by a twofold process
"or that which implies a single process,
"the worst of the two,
"and exasperates the subject."
What that means is
the guy who just hands out prescriptions,
that's one method.
The guy who listens to his patient
and examines him
correctly, that's another,
and you need to do both.
Now, as the French say,
plus ça change, plus c'est la même chose.
Is it not still the case
that far too frequently,
cursory, hasty, and therefore
not thorough or detailed
or respectful medical care
is dispensed to the poor
while the economically endowed
demand and get considered,
considerate and considered care,
and this situation raises
the philosophical question
that motivated all of Wittgenstein's,
all of, excuse me, Plato's investigations.
Can that state of affairs
be qualified as socially just?
While it is true that Plato did not ask,
which he should have done,
the question about the
institution of slavery,
I don't think there is more an up-to-date
or more fundamental question
to be asked of society now,
and I base this on
talking a lot to doctors,
to nurses, to occupational therapists,
to physiotherapists, all sorts of people.
The medical system, certainly in Ireland,
and also in England, is
under tremendous pressure,
and the people who get
the worst end of the stick
are, of course, the
economically deprived people,
and indeed, as I mentioned last day,
an influential group of philosophers,
all female,
argued in Oxford for
the continued importance
of values in running society,
especially the value of
justice and fairness,
so I just, I think I've talked
about them the last day,
but they have stayed,
they succeeded to introduce a new form of,
a new take on ethics,
which argued against the idea that
if it feels good for me, well, it's okay.
That's it. That's all.
That's the end of it.
If I feel good about it, okay.
What they were saying is
it has to be based on certain values,
behaviors that contribute
to your own goodness,
but also to those of others.
We do not live as isolated automatons.
We live in a social situation,
and in that, we find our fulfillment.
Now, you may query how it is
that philosophers still draw
inspiration from ancient texts,
from, like, Plato's dialogues,
which I've just been discussing with you,
and indeed, what started
out as Aristotle's notes
about which these female
philosophers based themselves,
and Drury discussed this practice
explicitly in his letters,
and he found his answer
in the perennial nature of philosophy,
and I've got the, he
found the point elaborated
in another one of Plato's
dialogues, the Republic,
and here you see it here.
"Dialectic philosophical interrogation,
"in fact, is the only activity
"whose method is to
challenge its own assumptions
"so that it may rest
firmly on first principles.
"Where the eye of the mind
"gets really bogged down
in a morass of ignorance,
"dialectic gently pulls
it out and leads it,"
so the Socratic method
of asking questions,
"What do you mean?"
And then you give an answer,
and they say, "What do you mean by that?
"And what do you mean
by meaning?" (laughs)
The contribution of philosophy
is actually the same
in every generation.
That's why the answers
that came before, you know,
are still relevant,
and it is to foster an
individual's interrogation,
and that includes every one of you,
of your own, and in particular,
our cultural assumptions.
By that I mean the
assumptions that come from us
that we come almost
with our mother's milk,
the kind of things that are assumed
in your family,
in your high school, in your university,
and we normally are not aware of that
unless we interrogate it,
and Drury believed
that a medical education
and practice, for example,
is not exhausted
by the accumulation of
information and experience,
particularly information.
It's not a question of learning,
learning about every drug
and every, you know, bodily organ
and about the interaction thereof.
It requires something more:
the willingness to
question medical practice
in terms of the values
espoused in its performance.
In other words, to ask questions
about the questions that medicine asks
because a doctor coming into
his consulting rooms
brings with it the kind of a suite
of assumptions and questions,
but maybe he's not asking
the right questions.
I once asked, I have an uncle.
He's now dead, but he was a farmer,
and I used to spend a lot of
time with him on the farm,
and much later, I asked him,
"Do you think I would
have made a good farmer?"
And he said, "No," and I said, "Why?"
I said, "Why?"
And he said, "You were
asking the wrong questions
"when you were aged five." (chuckles)
You have to,
you have to ask the right
questions to be a good farmer.
You have to ask the right
questions to be a good doctor,
and to ask these questions
is a philosophical interrogation.
Now, you will notice that in
the excerpt from the Laws,
which we read about the state's invalides,
Plato commends the free man's doctor,
who constructs an empirical case history
by consulting the
invalide and his friends.
In this way, he himself learns
something from the sick,
and at the same time,
he gives the individual patient
all the instruction he can.
In commending this approach,
Plato the philosopher is referencing
a fundamental medical institution:
the clinical interview,
the formal conversation
between doctor and patients,
and evidence of its Greek origins
can be found in the
very words we still use
to describe the phases of that interview.
You have that down here now.
Taking a history.
The Greek for that is anamnesis,
which is the very medical
practice singled out by Plato
as characteristic of and
worthy of a free man,
attentive listening to the
patient's story/narrative.
I note the emphasis placed on this phase
by Gawande and Sanders,
and it appears in Drury too,
and indeed, it is the case
that the dialogue between
doctor and patient
plays an especially central healing role
in Drury's specialty, psychiatry,
much more important than the pills.
The second is an examination
using, in addition to hearing,
the senses of sight and touch,
so you go on the couch,
and he uses his fingers, his hands
to help him to construct
an empirical case history.
Greek medicine, at its apogee,
which best in the Greek
doctor Galen of Pergamon,
which is Turkey, he practiced in Rome,
was characterized by the
recording of clinical histories
for comparison's sake.
Later on, with the invention
of the stethoscope in 1826,
the range of such examinations
are considerably increased,
and, of course, is now later augmented
by comprehensive laboratory tests
to the extent, however, as Gawande claims,
that testing has
overwhelmed medical systems.
It's all about testing.
Thirdly, in the medical interviews,
a diagnosis using anatomical
and with the development of history,
of medicine, physiology,
physiological and pathological models.
Modern medicine relied on such
medicines can be data to 1858
with the publication of
the book by Rudolf Virchow
called "Cellular Pathology,"
However, I note Professor Sanders' view,
"I saw that what I thought of as diagnosis
"was wrong much of the time
"or for the most exciting
parts, in any case.
"I found that diagnosis was
not the multiplication tables
"or the application of an algorithm,
"but more like Sherlock Holmes."
This insight faces us with
the presence of uncertainty
in medical investigation,
which means that it can never
be simply applying an algorithm.
That view is reinforced
by similar insights into
scientific investigation itself,
even stretching to the
level of quantum physics,
and I think I mentioned a
book last day that does that.
Fourthly, there's a prognosis,
again, a Greek word,
and a preferred method of treatment.
The goal of the clinical interview
is to arrive at a medical procedure
that will lead the embodied being,
very important in philosophy,
the embodied being,
not a defective machine,
and that's, of course,
where the problem comes.
We can understand machines
much better than we can
understand human beings.
To be restored to health,
the World Health
Organization described that
as a state of complete
physical, mental, and social wellbeing
and not merely the absence
of disease or infirmity.
Now, with that context sketched,
I want to see how I'm doing for time.
I am now in a position to relate
more of Drury's biography,
highlighting, in particular,
a letter where Wittgenstein
instructs Drury,
now a medical student,
along lines which are strikingly congruent
with Plato's critique of
current medical practice.
Drury was born in Wilshire in UK in 1907,
and, as I said,
both his parents were Irish-born,
but Anglican Christians,
that's to say members of
the Church of England,
and after his retirement
to Exeter in Devon,
Con Drury went to the
grammar school there.
While still at that high school,
that's the modern equivalent
of a grammar school,
he went up to Trinity
College in Cambridge in 1926
to study what was then called
the moral sciences, as I
mentioned, that's philosophy,
with a long-term plan
to take Anglican orders.
In Drury's third year at
Trinity College in Cambridge,
Ludwig Wittgenstein returned to Cambridge,
where he had studied
under Bertrand Russell,
that's all mentioned the last day,
for some years before the First World War
to teach philosophy.
He was immediately fell
under Wittgenstein's spell,
and thereafter,
almost all the vocational
decisions in his life
were strongly influenced, if
not dominated by his teacher.
Hence, although he resisted
Wittgenstein's counsel
to abandon his plan to enroll
in the Anglican theological
college at Cambridge,
Westcott House,
because Wittgenstein claimed,
"That clerical collar would choke you."
Drury left the seminary
after a year, in fact,
and then he followed Wittgenstein's advice
to live among ordinary people.
Wittgenstein was very strongly of the...
Wittgenstein himself had come from
probably the richest family in Austria,
and he gave away all his,
after returning from the First World War,
he gave away all his money
to his brothers and sisters,
and thereafter, he lived
very, very frugally,
and you have mentioned last day
that the number of different
kind of things he tried,
school teaching, gardening,
architecture, God knows,
but anyway, in Drury's case,
he was involved in schemes
to assist the vast number of
unemployed people in Britain
following the worldwide economic
depression of the 1930s,
which, of course, affected
life here in America as well,
and Wittgenstein's advice
was that such voluntary
work would be an antidote
to the too-narrow confines
of Drury's middle-class English society,
which was still affected
by Victorian manners,
very, very proper.
Wittgenstein frequently expressed a view
that teaching philosophy,
what he was doing himself,
was a ridiculous profession,
and so he was pleased when
Drury failed to be appointed
to an academic post in philosophy
when he applied for one about this time,
and later, a little later,
Wittgenstein intervened when Drury,
who's still needing to settle on a career,
was so moved by the
plight of a fellow worker
who had suffered a mental breakdown
that he wrote to Wittgenstein
that he was considering
becoming a psychiatric nurse.
Wittgenstein immediately suggested
that in view of his level of education,
Drury should instead
enroll in a medical school.
Drury said, "But I don't have the money."
Wittgenstein then went to
his friend Maynard Keynes,
the famous economist,
who spent every morning in bed until 12:00
playing the stock market on the telephone,
and Keynes came up with the cash.
They then settled on the medical school
at Trinity College in Dublin,
a very old medical school founded in 1711,
maybe slightly before
Yale itself was founded,
and mainly on the basis
that the fees there were
the cheapest they could find
and Dublin, of course, was
Drury's father's native city.
During the course of
Drury's medical studies,
Wittgenstein visited him
Dublin several times,
and I will return to an incident
that happened during one
of these visits later on.
At one stage, Wittgenstein asked Drury
to inquire of his tutor
at Trinity College, Dublin
whether Wittgenstein might join
him there to study medicine,
a request that, not surprisingly,
was greeted with astonishment.
Be like a Yale professor
applying to some medical school
in New York, Columbia maybe,
and saying, "Can I join?
"Can I become a doctor?"
You know, it's extraordinary.
The plan came to nothing,
but then Wittgenstein also was
thinking of going to Russia
and studying medicine, or
yeah, studying medicine there,
and you have to understand
that in that case,
in that environment in
Oxford-Cambridge in the 1930s,
Marxism was very, very popular,
and a lot of the people
there were communists
and actually, eventually
proved to be spies
during the Second World War,
and they thought
that Russia represented the future,
socialist Russia.
Here we are, (indistinct).
If you could give, pass that down.
Do you mind? Could you
pass it down, please?
So
anyway,
Drury was quite happy with
the scientific studies
and became first in his class,
studying physiology and, you
know, biology and all that,
but when he moved into the clinical phase
of his medical education,
he became, he suffered
a vocational crisis.
I can guarantee that you're
gonna suffer a vocational crisis
at some stage of your life,
maybe several of them.
I can tell you that for nothing.
I've been teaching students
your age for 40 years,
and some of the most creative and best
are the people that change their minds.
Anyway, Drury was very despondent,
very down in the dumps,
and Wittgenstein wrote him a letter,
and this letter is the own...
People, I archived all his writings,
and everybody, I mean, they've
come from all over the world
to Limerick, where I live,
and they all expect that in the archive
they're gonna find letters
that Wittgenstein wrote
to Drury,
and we know that he wrote many of them,
and there's only one that survives,
and I swear to God I haven't,
I'm not concealing anything.
There's only one,
and yeah, "Dear Drury, I
have thought a fair amount
"about our conversation on Sunday,
"and I would like to say,
or rather not to say,
"but write a few things
about these conversations.
"Mainly, I think this:
"Don't think about yourself,
but think about others,
"for example, your patients.
"You said in the Phoenix Park,"
that's the big park in
Dublin, "yesterday,"
where they spent a lot of time walking,
"that possibly you made a
mistake having taken up medicine.
"You immediately added
"that probably it was wrong
to think such a thing at all.
"I am sure it is, but not
because being a doctor,
"you may not, not because being a doctor
"you may not go the wrong
way or go to the dogs,
"but because if you do,
"this has nothing to do
"with your choice of a
profession being a mistake,
"for what human being can say
"what would have been the right thing
"if this is the wrong one?
"You didn't make a mistake
"because there was nothing at the time
"you knew or ought to have
known that you overlooked.
"You did your best.
"Only this could have been
called making a mistake,
"and even if you made a
mistake in this sense,
"this would now have to
be regarded as datum,
"as all the other circumstances
inside and outside,
"which you can't alter.
"The thing now is to live in
the world in which you are,
"not to think of or dream about
"the world you would like to be in.
"Look at people's sufferings,
physical and mental.
"You have them close at hand,
"and this ought to be a good
remedy for your troubles.
"Another way is to take a rest
"whenever you ought to take
one and collect yourself.
"Not with me because I wouldn't rest you.
"As for religious thoughts,
"I do not think the craving
for placidity is religious,
"which is often how religion is sold:
"something one ought to hunt after.
"Look at your patients more closely
"as human beings in trouble,
"and enjoy more the opportunity you have
"to say 'goodnight' to many people.
"This alone is a gift from heaven,
"which many people would envy you,
"and this sort of thing ought to heal you
"and heal your frail soul, I believe.
"It won't rest it, but when
you are healthily tired,
"you may, you can just take a rest.
"I think, in some sense, you
don't look at people's face,
"the window of the soul, closely enough.
"In conversations with me,
"don't so much try to
have the conversations
"which you think would taste well,
"though you will never get that anyway,
"but try to have the conversations
"which will have the
pleasantest aftertaste.
"It is most important
"that we should not one
day have to tell ourselves
"that we had wasted the time
"we were allowed to spend together.
"I wish you good thoughts,
but chiefly, good feelings."
For my part, I see many echoes here
of Plato's contrast between medical care,
worthy of free man,
and his implied criticism
of the kind of doctor
who never gives any account
of the particular illness
of the individual slave
or is prepared to listen to one,
but simply prescribes
what he thinks best in
the light of experience
as if he had precise knowledge
and with the self-confidence
of a dictator.
That's the end of the quote from Plato.
Immediately after the
war, after the graduating,
Drury joined the Royal Army Medical Corps,
and he had a pretty rough time.
He had a easy time in Egypt, in Cairo,
but afterwards, he followed,
in a tented hospital,
the advance of the army.
He was landed on the beaches at Normandy
and then followed the advance
of the army, the British Army,
across Northern France
and into Holland,
and then the Battle of the Bulge,
in which American soldiers
distinguished themselves greatly,
and he was in a tented hospital,
and it was rough going.
He returned to Dublin after the war,
after five years of service.
During the war,
Wittgenstein himself worked,
even though he was professor
of philosophy in Cambridge,
he went up there a day or two a week,
but for the rest, he worked
in Guy's Hospital in London
as a porter
and a pharmaceutical assistant,
which meant he went 'round the
wards bringing the medicines,
and then he got involved
in a research project regarding shock,
shock that came to people
after they had the
bombing in London, really,
I mean, I can think of the same
thing in Kiev at the moment,
and Ukraine generally, you know,
it does leave huge marks on the
people who have been bombed,
and anyway, he never really
settled in philosophy
after that point,
and eventually, he decided that he might,
there was a book in him
that he wanted to write in the 1930s,
the book which he never finished,
but was published posthumously
as the "Philosophical Investigations."
This is Wittgenstein,
and so there were two men in crisis,
and eventually, Drury
secured a six-month contract
in St. Patrick's Psychiatric Hospital
in Dublin,
which was actually
founded by Jonathan Swift
the writer of "Gulliver's Travels,"
and he actually stuck with psychiatry
and stayed there until he retired
with cardiac-related symptoms.
He died on Christmas day in 1976.
That's Drury,
so Wittgenstein, after retiring, decided,
"Will I go to Norway," where
he had a hut on a fjord,
"or will I go to Ireland?"
He came back to Ireland,
and while there,
he got a very, very severe mental,
he became very severely mentally ill,
and he was referred by
Drury to Drury's boss,
Professor Norman Moore.
Again, we don't know an awful lot
about what the problem was,
but eventually,
he went to the wildest
part of Ireland, Connemara,
and to a cottage that Drury's
elder brother had there.
Wittgenstein died of prostatic cancer
in 1951
in the home of a medical
friend of Drury's,
Dr. Bevan in Cambridge.
Now, at the beginning,
I quoted from Plato,
and now I want to quote from Drury
about an event which took
place a good deal earlier
in Dublin in 1936.
Drury recalled,
"When I was a medical
student here in Dublin,
"and Wittgenstein came over to visit me,
"he wanted to give talks
with some mental patients.
"I arranged for him to go
to St. Patrick's Hospital,"
that's the psychiatric hospital,
"as a visit whenever he wanted to.
"There was one old man
"who had been in the
hospital for many years,
"and Wittgenstein said about him,
"'He was much more
intelligent that his doctors.'
"This man had read a
lot of Herbert Spencer,"
that's the evolutionary theorist,
"and one day,
"when he was having a
discussion with Wittgenstein,
"I was there too,
"and I attempted to join in
"with some rather shallow
logical positivism,"
which was the then-fashionable philosophy
in England (indistinct)
to a book by A.J. Ayer,
which actually summarized
trends in philosophy
which had developed in Vienna,
Wittgenstein's home city,
and very much influenced by Wittgenstein,
but Wittgenstein never, ever agreed
that anybody could speak for him,
"so Wittgenstein told me to
shut up when he intervened,"
when Drury intervened in this
discussion with the patient.
"Later, when he was talking
about it on our own,
"he said, 'When you are playing ping-pong,
"'you shouldn't use a tennis racket.'"
In other words, be sensitive.
Now, amazingly, Albert Camus,
have you ever heard of him?
A French writer, a philosopher,
extremely interesting man as well.
He tells a very similar story,
but has an interesting twist in it.
I got it here.
He said, "In a psychiatric hospital,
"a passing doctor noticed
one of his patients
"fishing with a rod in a bathtub."
Imagine it.
"As he walked by,
"mindful of this indispensable partnership
"between two human beings,
"the doctor asked the
patient, 'Are they biting?'"
the fish in the bathtub, (chuckles)
"to which the patient replied, 'Idiot!
"'Can't you even see that it
is a bathtub?'" (chuckles)
So yeah, (laughs)
Now, I have stressed very much
that this all depends on
the store of experience
and the examined life that a
doctor brings to his patients,
and by experience, I
think I can't do better
than quote from one of
Wittgenstein's favorite novelists,
Dostoevsky in "The Brothers Karamazov."
"It was said by many people
about the elder Zossima
"that by permitting
everyone for so many years
"to come to bare their souls and hearts
"and beg his advice and healing words,
"he had absorbed
"so many secrets, sorrows,
and avowals into his soul
"that in the end, he had
acquired so fine a perception
"that he could tell at the first glance
"from the face of a stranger
"what he had come for, what he wanted,
"and what kind of torment
wracked his conscience."
Wittgenstein assured Drury,
"Yes, there really have
been people like that,
"and indeed, I believe that our doctors
"and other health professionals
"who can read their patients,
as it were, at a glance,
"but unfortunately, this is a facility
"which is feigned in the reality,
"and it's absented in the slave doctor
"who briskly proceeds from bed to bed
"and pretends he can read
the patient like that,"
but there are people who can read,
can zoom in straightaway.
Now, will I go on
for just a few more minutes?
I mentioned earlier
that Drury collected, in
"The Danger of Words,"
a number of papers he'd originally given,
mainly to groups of doctors,
as an illustration of the influence
that Wittgenstein had on him.
"I notice here references to problems,
"practical difficulty, and perplexity."
I haven't given you the full quotation.
"By way of introduction to another facet
"of the relationship between
philosophy and medicine
"that is much more problematic
"than we have discussed so far.
"That concerns the role
"of scientific investigation in medicine,
"and that, too, had definite,
albeit not exclusive, origins
"in certain philosophical trends.
"It's because of the
philosophy of the physics
"that where they decided
"that there were four
"elementary subjects,
"substances that go to make up the world:
"earth, air, fire, and water.
"This was reflected in the body
"in four elementary bodily fluids:
"phlegm, yellow bile,
black bile, and blood,
"all in a dynamic balance,"
and well into the 19th century,
the medical practice of
bloodletting was justified
on the pretext of restoring
the bodily fluids,
that if you had kind of a,
I'm putting a flushed face, you should,
some blood would be drawn
by leeches, little animals,
"so this was actually in contravention
"of what the Greek idea of medicine was,
"which was that one should rely
"mainly on the natural
powers of the body to heal,
"and as is obvious,
"this power lies outside the
direct control of the doctor.
"The Greek philosophers saw
similarity in that respect
"with their own art, which was teaching.
"At the last resort,
"the power to learn does
not lie with the teacher,
"no more than the power
to heal with the doctor."
I can't make you learn anything, you know?
But you do learn.
You learn because you want to learn,
and in a certain sense,
what they were saying is
that you can rely on the body to heal,
and just so I can rely on
your intelligence to learn,
and nature is the primary healer,
at least that was the Greek
conviction,
and a very important German
philosopher of medicine
called Hans-Georg Gadamer,
characterized healing as
enigmatic on that account,
and perhaps we can let fly the cinnamons,
difficult to interpret, mysterious even,
to amplify what Drury was getting at.
Now, I was going to
talk to you a little bit
about interventionist medicine
and trace it back to Francis Bacon
and also to Descartes,
but I think you've probably
heard a lot about that,
but basically, these guys said,
"Intervene, intervene, intervene.
"Get involved with...
They all admitted that the
current science got you nowhere.
"But this,
"it had a huge promissory value,
"and health would become the foundation
"of all the other blessings
in this life," said Bacon,
and what they were looking for was
a cure for incurable diseases,
the enhancement of human capacity,
the prolonging of life, even.
You know, these are still
things where we're at,
and these promissory notes
were taken up over time
in the universities,
whereas now, I think,
the medical faculties
have a primacy far, far greater
than the arts and humanities faculties.
You know, that's how it's,
that's what's happened.
Now, this kind of philosophical reflection
privileging science has had
many consequences for medicine.
The doctor or medical researcher
are portrayed as dealing
with the body only,
often modeled on a machine
such that machine is an
extension of engineering
with the brain modeled on the computer,
software to hardware,
but there's always the feeling
there's something more,
and more that features, inescapably,
in the interpersonal negotiation
that is the ancient and
venerable medical interview.
Wittgenstein entered into this debate,
and in his earlier book,
he ends with, "Whereof one cannot speak,
"therefore one must be silent.
"You can speak science,
"but the other things,
"about which you cannot speak,
"the appreciation of beauty in aesthetics,
"the values that ought to be exemplified
"in one's behavior in ethics,
"the wonder at the very existence
of the world, mysticism,
"in these cases, all you can do," he said,
"at that point, is look and point."
Look at that. Feel that.
That matters.
Later on, he modified that somewhat
with the notion of language games,
but he was against,
which we've discussed last day, scientism.
I'm coming to an end.
I'm sure he was influenced in
his own criticism of science,
and remember, he started
out like was an engineer.
By his own experience of
the mechanized slaughter
in the trenches of the First World War,
the industrial-scale
extermination of the Jews,
a heritage he could claim
as his own under the Nazis,
and after 1945,
the nuclear threat that
still hangs over mankind
with Mr. Putin,
and all these are examples
of the abuse of science
unforeseen by Descartes or Bacon,
so put it this way:
Wittgenstein, and Drury picked this up,
was an anti-Cartesian,
anti- seeing a huge separation
between mind and body.
We are embodied beings,
and ne'er can the two be separated,
and they're separated only,
at their separation gives
an entree into science
into areas where it
shouldn't go and can't go.
Nevertheless, Drury,
and with Wittgenstein's approval,
were welcomed the use of
pharmacology in psychiatry,
which happened in the 1950s, I suppose,
but he, Wittgenstein, warned,
"Don't let yourself think
"that all human problems
can be solved in this way.
"They can't.
"Although our intelligence
and our willpower
"are dependent on the proper functioning
"of a very complicated and delicate
"neurohumoral mechanism
"over which we have no control,
"our sanity is at the mercy of a molecule,
"but that does not mean
"that all the answers lie
on that level of analysis."
In mental illness, Drury stressed
the terrifying loneliness
of the experience of mental illness,
but he said, "A loneliness
"that can make the sufferer more aware
"of the mysteriousness
of our present being.
"Indeed, the patient may
thereby gain insights
"not yet appreciated
by his medical carer."
As Wittgenstein remarked
to the patient in St. Patrick's Hospital,
"I think this man is much more intelligent
"than any of his doctors."
In sum, mental illness
can make the enigma of
each person apparent,
not only to the sufferer,
but for those who care for him or her,
especially, perhaps, the medical carer,
and it is because of that enigma
with its attendant uncertainty
that medical practice continues to be
as much an art as it is a science.
This art can only be mastered
by an onerous apprenticeship
such as Drury experienced.
Through that apprenticeship,
the doctor learns when to intervene
using valuable scientific resources,
and when to let nature
take its healing course.
This discrimination is
especially important
when the doctor faces
his or her last task,
the palliative one of
conducting the patient
to the gates of the unknown at our death.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(ethereal music)